>> Linda Holmes: Hi, everybody.
>> Hi.
>> Linda Holmes: Welcome
to marine invertebrates.
I think that's pretty
cool; right?
[ Applause ]
Any marine invertebrates
here today?
Anybody? No.
My name is Linda Holmes,
and I work at NPR.
I host a podcast called
Pop Culture Happy Hour.
And I am not a scientist.
But when I had the opportunity
to find an interesting event
to perhaps help moderate,
I gravitated to this one
because it looked so
interesting to me.
So I dove right in, so to speak.
Sorry. Terrible water puns.
And we're going to have a chat.
I'm going to ask both of you
to introduce yourselves,
if you would.
Because, since I'm
not a scientist,
I'm afraid I'll say
something wrong.
So, Sy, you want to
introduce yourself.
>> Sy Montgomery:
I'm Sy Montgomery.
And, gosh, often I introduce
myself as a former swine herd.
But we just had one pig.
My, a previous book was
called "The Good Good Pig."
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Linda Holmes: Yes, yes.
>> Sy Montgomery: So,
but this is my first book
about a marine invertebrate.
Everybody else I've written
about in my 26 books has
been vertebrate animals.
But most of the world, as
we know, most of the animals
on the world are invertebrates.
And most of them
live in the sea.
>> Linda Holmes:
It's a big place.
Lots of animals.
Juli, you want to
introduce yourself.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
I'm Juli Berwald.
And I used to be a scientist.
And now I'm a science writer.
And, let's see, I
often introduce myself
as a science writer.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
So, and I apologize
for doing that.
Because really normally I would
give the lovely introduction.
But I was so afraid,
like I said,
that I would misstate something.
Because this is, as I
said, not really my field.
But it was fascinating
to me as a layperson.
Which I think with both of
your books, they are meant
to have sort of not just a
science-directed viewpoint.
But they are meant to mean
something to people even
if they don't have a
strong basis in science.
Is that right, Sy?
>> Sy Montgomery:
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
And I am not a scientist.
I'm just a writer.
But the layperson is the
person that has the power
over whether this sweet
green world survives or not.
So I'm honored to be
writing for that audience.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
Is that true of you too, Juli?
>> Juli Berwald:
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, you know, when I
got the idea to write a book
about jellyfish, I was like,
who wants to read a
book about jellyfish?
And then I, but then
I realized, you know,
I think anyone might want to
read a book about jellyfish
if it's written so that
there's other things in there
that make it a compelling read.
And I really had in mind I want
to write a book about science
that people who never have read
science before might enjoy.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Juli Berwald: So that
was a big part of, yeah,
that was big part
of my motivation.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
So I'm going to start,
Juli, why jellyfish?
And people who have read the
book know some of this story.
But what is it about jellyfish?
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
They're definitely the
underdog character, so to speak.
But, yeah, jellyfish are
telling us about, they're sort
of the opposite of the
canary in the coal mine.
In that there's a lot of places
in the world, more than half
of the coastlines
where jellyfish numbers
seem to be on the rise.
They're abundances are growing.
And for, the reasons
are a lot of the things
that we are doing to the ocean.
So things like coastal
development
without really thinking
about what we're doing.
Overfishing.
Shipping. You know,
building big canals.
These things that
seem kind of distant
from us are affecting
the jellyfish.
So the jellyfish gave me this
platform to talk about things
that are really, really
important in a global sense.
But from a really
interesting angle that a lot
of people didn't
know much about.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
Okay, Sy, why octopuses.
And I will say, Less, do
you think I am illiterate?
And they are struggling
not to correct me.
It is octopuses, am I right?
>> Sy Montgomery: Absolutely.
>> Linda Holmes: Okay.
>> Sy Montgomery: I
grew up hearing octopi.
But apparently that
is incorrect.
Or at least you will be
corrected if you talk
to the people who
study these animals.
So we got to stay in
their good graces.
>> Linda Holmes: Absolutely.
>> Sy Montgomery: So
octopuses, as I said,
I'd written about lots
of vertebrates before.
I have 26 different books
from snow leopards to pigs.
To, I actually did have
another eight legger,
but he was a tarantula.
But octopuses are so unlike us.
You know, we're separated
by half a billion
years of evolution.
Their bodies don't even go,
you know, head, body, limbs.
They go body, head, limbs.
The part that you think is the
head is really what we consider
the torso where the
excretory and reproductive
and respiratory organs
are located.
They taste with their skin.
They have three hearts.
And yet they're capable of
these incredible superpowers.
They can, with one 3.5-inch
sucker, lift 30 pounds.
And a giant Pacific octopus has
200 on each of its eight arms.
And as different
as this animal is,
you can still have a
friend who's an octopus.
So the octopus afforded me a
way to look at consciousness
in the animal world
at a time that I felt
that readers might be hungering
for that kind of connection.
And, boy, did they, did they
ever fulfill everything you
could ever.
I had no idea that I would
fall in love with an octopus
so much that, when the
animal died, I wept.
And I had no idea that
these octopuses would kind
of be the core of this group of
fabulous disparate friendships
that kind of cut across taxa.
Some of us were vertebrates.
Some of us invertebrates.
Some of us were marine.
Some were freshwater.
And others were terrestrial.
>> Linda Holmes: You talk in the
book about scientists wanting
to avoid anthropomorphising
animals.
You know, your dog doesn't
want to go to the prom
and all that kind of stuff.
That they don't dream of
a future in the same way
that people do and
those kinds of things.
What do you think?
Because obviously, as you say,
you came out of the book talking
about having a friendship
with this octopus.
Where did you come down
in terms of the dangers
of anthropomorphising too
much versus the dangers
of not understanding
commonalities enough?
>> Sy Montgomery: Well,
I feel that modern people
in the western world
error on the wrong side.
I think the biggest mistake you
can make is deny that the rest
of animate creation has
no thoughts or feelings.
That they lack emotion.
I have found every single animal
I've ever known clearly seems
to love its life
the same way I do.
And if you error in the opposite
direction, that's just going
to make you a more
compassionate person.
But if you make the mistake
of denying them the dignity
of having a mind, well,
that error is a much
more grievous sin.
>> Linda Holmes: Did you
feel self-conscious at all
when you found yourself
in grief for an octopus?
Did it feel strange?
>> Sy Montgomery:
Did it feel odd?
Well, no because I was so
overwhelmed with the emotion.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: But here's
the interesting thing.
I mean, I don't think that
the octopuses that I knew felt
about me the same way
I felt about them.
But I know that they
liked when I showed up.
Because we know from
scientific experiments
that octopuses do recognize
individual human faces just
looking up through the water.
We know this from
scientific experiments.
And we also know that they like
some people and dislike others.
And we know that because,
if they don't like you,
they will jet away often
after blasting you in the face
with 47-degree freezing
cold ice water.
So that's pretty clear.
And if they like you,
they will come over.
Their arms with come
boiling up out of the water,
and they will embrace
you with their suckers.
They'll play with you.
And if they feel excited
to see you, they turn red.
If they feel very
calm in your presence,
they'll turn white
beneath your touch.
So I know they felt something.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: Good about me.
Juli, one of the things
that I thought was
so interesting reading these
two books together was that,
whereas, it seems like a lot of
Sy's journey with the octopus is
about the octopus
as an individual.
A lot of the journey with the
jellyfish is the jellyfish
as a bigger phenomenon
and species.
And, in fact, you had an effort
to sort of keep some jellyfish
at home more like pets
that did not take.
>> Juli Berwald: Don't do it.
I mean, you can't, I
shouldn't say that.
Some people can do it.
But I think it requires,
you know,
a big filtration
system and, yeah.
When I was working on the book,
I heard about this
kick-starter for jellyfish pets.
And I ordered it.
I got, you know, first in
line, and I got this tank.
And I put it in the dining room.
And I got three jellyfish.
And my kids named them
peanut, butter and jelly.
And we, you know, we tried
to keep them for a while.
And it was really fantastic
having them in our dining room
where I could kind of
be mesmerized by them.
And they are super.
There is something
about watching a jellyfish
move that's extremely relaxing.
And it seems to kind of hit
in this place of your heart.
And, in fact, the jellyfish,
around the edge of their bell,
they have these many
little faces sort of.
That it, where their
sensory organs are.
And there's a thing
called a pacemaker.
And it's, that's the
technical word for it,
right next to each face.
And that controls how fast
the jellyfish pulse is.
So there's actually like this.
>> Linda Holmes: It's
like a lava lamp.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
They're like watching
lava lamps.
Right. And they do seem
to sort of make you calm.
But they don't like
living in living rooms.
Especially not in Austin, Texas.
And so it was like kind of the
goldfish from the carnival.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Juli Berwald: Situation.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
But I did enjoy very
much having, you know,
thinking about them on
an individual level.
Although I think with
jellyfish maybe some
of the more interesting
ideas are kind
of the global questions
about them.
Not that it isn't with
octopuses as well.
They have really
interesting global questions.
And questions of how.
>> Sy Montgomery: They have,
I think jellyfish
have less personality.
>> Juli Berwald: They do have.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Sy Montgomery:
They do lack a brain.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
On an individual basis.
Although, you know,
much is unknown.
And also the question,
how do you define
intelligence, is a big question.
How do you define pain
is a big question.
And those things aren't
really very well understood.
>> Sy Montgomery: Yeah,
you're absolutely right.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Juli Berwald:
Especially for invertebrates.
>> Sy Montgomery: Yeah.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: Yeah,
it's a whole other world.
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
>> Sy Montgomery: And
with octopuses it's easy
because their intelligence
is so like ours.
They love to play with toys.
They love to play with the same
toys that our kids play with.
They love Legos.
They love Mr. Potato Head.
>> Linda Holmes: There was one
playing with a Kong; right?
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh, yeah.
They love the Kong.
>> Linda Holmes:
My dog has a Kong.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Sy Montgomery: Same
thing you give to a dog.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And, you know, they
make up games.
So that's an intelligence that
we can recognize and respect.
They like to solve problems.
How do I open this jar?
I mean, they'll open a jar.
Take the treat out of the jar.
But then just for fun, some
of them will just
screw the top back on.
And the other thing they love
to solve is how do I
get out of my tank?
And that probably didn't happen.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
They're really good at that.
>> Sy Montgomery: Yeah.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah, that
made me think a lot about,
is it "Finding Dory"
where there's an octopus?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Sy Montgomery: Yes, Hank.
>> Linda Holmes: I
think that hangs out.
>> Sy Montgomery: Hank.
>> Linda Holmes: And
goes all over the floor.
And when I first saw that
in the theater, I thought,
well, that's very silly.
But apparently not.
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh, yeah.
>> Linda Holmes: Apparently
that was that Pixar accuracy.
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh, they have
been known to make break for it.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: I
mean, they've crawled
out of home aquariums
and gotten halfway
across the lawn trying
to get to the sea.
And, you know, attacked by ants.
Or, you know, one got
out in someone's house
and was found in a teapot.
And there were others, there's
many stories of octopuses
that got out of their tank
and devoured everybody
else in the adjacent tank.
And some of them are said to
have snuck back in their tank
where then they could
just sit like this.
>> Linda Holmes: Except
with eight; right?
>> Sy Montgomery: Yeah, right.
That's right.
>> Juli Berwald:
Can he we just stick
up for the jellyfish
for a second.
So the jellyfish may not have a
brain, but they do have, like,
very interesting
sensory abilities; right?
So they sting.
Like, that's their way of
getting around in the world,
is they sting with
these stinging cells.
Which you probably know,
if you've ever been stung.
And that stinging cell explodes
with an acceleration
of 5 million G's.
So that's like 5 million times
the acceleration of gravity.
And it's the fastest motion
in the animal kingdom.
But jellyfish don't
sting each other; right?
>> Sy Montgomery: Wow.
>> Juli Berwald: So somehow
they know, this is my species.
I shouldn't sting them
unless I want to eat them.
And so they don't do that.
They also, you know, they have,
on those little faces
I was talking about.
They have eye spots.
And they can see.
And they have a touch plate
where they can smell
and sense currents.
And so they will accumulate
where there's food.
They migrate up and
down, day to night
so that they don't get eaten
by birds diving into the water.
I mean, they have, they're the
oldest swimmers on our planet.
So they have some intelligence
in a way or something.
These survival skills
that have allowed them
to stay around this long.
So I just had to
stick up for them.
>> Sy Montgomery: No, no,
you're absolutely right.
>> Juli Berwald: They
can't unscrew a jar.
But they've been here
longer than any of us.
>> Sy Montgomery: But it's a
different kind of intelligence.
>> Juli Berwald: It's different.
>> Sy Montgomery: That
we don't appreciate.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: Because
it's not like ours.
>> Juli Berwald: Exactly.
>> Sy Montgomery: What freaks me
out about octopus is
that, here's the thing.
It doesn't look like us at all.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
>> Sy Montgomery: That's
squeezes its boneless body
through an opening the size of
an orange if it's 100 pounds.
That tastes with its skin.
And has blue blood.
And it's brain is
wrapped around its throat.
And yet we recognize
and appreciate a lot
of its intelligence.
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
>> Sy Montgomery: It's
so similar to ours.
Their eyes are very
similar to ours.
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
Wait, but, okay, so
this is really cool.
Like, now octopuses have eyes
that are similar to ours.
They're like camera eyes.
And the box jelly,
which is, you know,
the most toxic animal
in the world.
It has 8 eyes that
are camera eyes.
Just like ours do.
They have 24 eyes and
8 of them have a lens.
A retina. And an iris that opens
and closes in response to light.
And that's jellyfish.
So that's, yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: Well,
who needs a brain?
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
That's the question.
I mean, it's a very
good question.
>> Sy Montgomery: Just because
you don't have a brain doesn't
mean you don't have any sense.
>> Juli Berwald: Exactly.
>> Sy Montgomery: So.
>> Linda Holmes: Well, it
raises an interesting question,
what you're talking about.
Not only what do we
mean by intelligence?
Which I think is one thing
that you're both talking about.
But what do we mean by a soul.
In the title of your book
"The Soul of an Octopus,"
what do you mean by a soul?
What does a soul mean to you?
>> Juli Berwald: I'm glad
that's your question.
>> Sy Montgomery: No, no.
This was something I've
given a lot of thought.
I mean, I think all of
us wonder, you know,
do we even have a soul?
Is a soul the same
thing as a self?
Is a self the component of
consciousness that matters?
And there's different
philosophers that look
at this in different ways.
And some philosophers,
human philosophers will say
that we don't have selves.
Well, I thought I did.
But, you know, they'll even say
we don't have a self much less
a soul.
I was raised in a Methodist
church, so I believed
that humans and animals
had a soul.
And I always believed
that there was something
of the holy in the soul.
And when I look around
at all the lives
that animate this world, I feel,
there's this great quote that's
attributed to Thales of Miletus.
That says the universe is alive.
Has fire in it and
is full of gods.
And to me that says that
this world that we live
in is so much more alive.
And so much more incandescent.
And so much more holy
than we might dare dream.
So I would say, yes,
octopuses have a soul.
And I would say jellyfish
have a soul.
And that we should behave
towards them as if they are holy
in the same way that
our lives are holy.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
I mean, yes.
Jellyfish have this really
interesting situation.
And they have a very
complicated lifecycle.
And they, the medusa
part that we're familiar
with is only a very small
part of their lifecycle.
Much of it is lived as a polyp,
which is like a sea anemone.
And that polyp actually
slices itself horizontally.
And then each one of those
pancakes, I guess, pops off
and becomes a medusa
that we see.
And then that polyp, which is
planted on the bottom of a dock
or the underside of a, you know,
jetty or something like that.
It can grow again and
do the same thing.
It's called strobilation,
where it cuts itself
into these like 24 slices.
And then they all pop
off and become medusa
over and over and over.
And so I was talking to
some jellyfish scientists,
and I said.
Are we thinking about jellyfish
correctly when we think
about them as animals?
Aren't they more plantlike,
where the polyp is
sort of like the tree?
And the medusa are like
the apples, you know,
casting themselves off to
reproduce and form new trees?
And the jellyfish scientists,
and I really had been
thinking about that, you know.
Sometimes, when trees
are stressed,
they will produce a lot
of offspring in order
to find places where there's
a better place to be living.
And I was thinking
about the oceans
and how we're damaging them.
And maybe these blooms of
jellyfish were happening
because they're trying
to find new habitat.
And the jellyfish
scientists cautioned me,
and they were like, no.
Don't think about it like that.
Because of what you said,
because they're animals.
And to deny their
animal nature means
that you don't understand
the jellyfish.
And so I think that, yes, you
know, jellyfish are animated
by the same thing that
animates all animals.
And it's very important
to remember that.
And to realize, I mean, I think
the jellyfish are telling us
something about the damage
we're doing to our oceans.
And that they're animals that
are, you know, proliferating.
And we should pay
attention to those signals.
>> Linda Holmes: How do you?
>> Juli Berwald: Kind
of got a little away
from the soul thing but, yeah.
>> Linda Holmes: No,
I mean, I think part
of what you're getting
at in the book is
that the jellyfish I think, as
I said, I think the inspection
of the octopus is a
little more individual.
And the inspection
of the jellyfish is
more at a species level.
But they're both,
like Sy was saying,
they're both something
holy and meaningful.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Linda Holmes: Because one
of the things that you talk
about is how the jellyfish, the
role that the jellyfish plays
in so many different
parts of the ecosystems
that they, where they live.
Because they're both, they
prey on certain things
and are preyed upon by
certain things and all of that.
Is that true?
>> Juli Berwald:
It's true, yeah.
And so the thing about jellyfish
is that we don't know as much
about them as we wish we did.
And part of that is because
the way we studied the oceans
in most of the 20th century.
Once we got boats and
motors and winches and nets.
Where it's really fast.
We drive through the ocean.
Pull these big nets
behind the boats.
Pull everything up and dump
it on the back of the ship.
And then sort through it.
And that, jellyfish don't
handle that treatment very well.
So we obliterated our baseline
for understanding jellyfish.
And, in fact, sometimes they
would pour bleach on the boat
to really dissolve
away the jellyfish
and disable their stings.
So, yeah, so we don't know a
lot about what's, you know,
this is one of the big
controversies in the book
that I try to uncover.
Is this question of
what's really happening
with the jellyfish?
And it's very hard to tell
because the baseline is so poor.
And I forgot the question.
>> Linda Holmes: Well, I'm
not sure the question was,
I think you probably did
a better job answering
than the question did asking.
>> Juli Berwald:
Oh, the [inaudible].
>> Linda Holmes: I did
want to ask you both.
One of the things that the
jellyfish and the octopus have
in common is a sort of a
history of perceived menace.
Because you talk about
the octopus and the kind
of the giant of the sea.
And the whole idea of
boats being sucked under
and all of that business.
Where do you, did
you wind up feeling
like that's an overblown
idea given the likelihood
that people have actually
ever seen an octopus that big?
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh,
honest to god, yeah.
I mean, I'm always on the side
of the underdog, you know.
I just wrote a book
about hyenas.
And I'm working about
one on vultures.
So, you know, but they're
magnificent creatures, you know.
Hyenas actually one of
the top predators, steals.
He doesn't steal his
food from the lion.
The lion steals from him.
And you can go on and on and on.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: And on.
But it's wonderful to be
able to find something
that looks like it's one way.
And then discovering
it's the opposite.
And particularly with an animal
like a jellyfish or an octopus.
Because both are you such agents
and symbols of transformation.
When you were talking
about, you know,
how you start out as a medusa.
Which looks like
something that you found
on the bottom of your shoe.
And then grows up to become one
of the most beautiful
things you can ever imagine.
And octopuses are, you
know, as people know,
they change color and shape.
They can sprout spots
or stripes.
They can change color
in less than a second.
At first they look like a
whole of striped snakes.
And the next thing you know
they're looking look a piece
of coral.
And, no, they're something else.
And I think that's why both
of these animals, I think,
can speak to us at a time
that our very Earth is
under going this huge
transformational, huge change.
And for me the octopus was
an agent of transformation.
Because it opened the
world to me in a way
that had never been
opened before.
And as I was writing about
these animals and learning
about the sea, at the
same time the institution
where I was getting to
know the octopuses best,
I did learn to scuba dive.
But the ones that I knew
best lived at the aquarium.
It was undergoing a
huge transformation.
It was being, it was
rebuilding the giant ocean tank.
And so change was all around us.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
And the jellyfish, there are
some harrowing jellyfish stories
in the book.
The Diana Nyad story is.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Linda Holmes: Amazing.
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh, my god.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
I mean, jellyfish, you know,
they have definitely been seen
as an agent of menace.
And, you know, they, some
of them do deserve it.
I mean, not, but, you
know, you have to remember
that we are not, we're not
the object of their sting.
The prey is.
We just get in their way.
And so, yeah, the story, the
box jellies that I mentioned,
the ones with the 24 eyes,
8 of which are camera eyes.
They are also the most toxic
group of jellyfish in the world.
And one of them can
kill in three minutes.
It's perhaps the most
toxic animal in the world.
And Diana Nyad, who I'm
not sure if you know.
She was, she's an
amazing long-distance
competitive swimmer.
And at something like 63,
decided to swim from Cuba
to the Keys, the Florida Keys.
And she tried four
times and failed.
Not because she wasn't
strong enough.
Not because she couldn't handle
the salt water chafing inside
her throat.
Not because she couldn't
stay up for the 53 hours
that it takes to swim that far.
But because of jellyfish
stinging her.
So she actually had to put
together like a jellyfish team
and develop gear that went
all the way down her throat.
So that she wouldn't
get stung in her mouth.
And she did it on the last try.
She's the only person to
have ever made that swim.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Juli Berwald: But she had a
jellyfish scientist pretty much
swimming beside her
the whole time.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
Did you, Sy, when you were
talking before about the kind
of the relationship
with the octopus.
And meeting the octopus.
And how they welcome
and greet you.
The description in the
book of kind of your first
up close encounter with an
octopus is, I'm not going
to say it's like a
love scene exactly.
But it's very tactile.
It's a very kind of,
you use a comparison
to a kiss quite a bit.
What was that moment
of encountering
that octopus like for you?
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh, man.
Well, it was really
transformative.
I'd never known anyone
like that before.
Also, very seldom, you know, are
people feeling and tasting you
so early in your relationship.
[ Laughing ]
And other people who
have put their hands
in with an octopus
have recoiled.
Because, okay, it is cold.
It is slimy.
They're sucking on you.
You're going to have
to go home and explain
to your husband why you
are covered would hickies
after [inaudible].
So, but I was never at all
afraid when I first met Athena.
Even though she was
pulling me into the tank.
But I wanted to go
into the tank.
But I knew I wouldn't fit.
And I also had some
strong people there
who would pull me
out of the tank.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery:
If I needed to.
Interestingly, though,
octopuses are also venomous.
They are all venomous.
And some are deadly.
But I never worried that
these octopuses would bite me.
And only once have I seen
someone bitten by an octopus.
And the octopus chosen
to envenomate.
So isn't that nice.
>> Juli Berwald: That's
cool they can choose whether
or not to envenomate.
>> Sy Montgomery: Yes, totally.
Yeah. And, of course,
they choose whether or not
to bite you in the first place.
And I think, you know, when this
octopus, her nail was Colley.
And she bit a friend of
mine, a teenager named Anna.
And here's the cool
thing about octopuses.
I mean, talk about
sensitive new age guy.
They are tasting and
feeling you at the same time.
And they're not just
tasting, I believe,
the surface of your skin.
But I think they can
taste the blood beneath.
>> Juli Berwald: Wow.
>> Sy Montgomery: And
I think the reason
that she was bitten was she was
on various different medicines.
And she had changed
her medicine.
I think she tasted differently.
>> Juli Berwald: Wow.
>> Sy Montgomery: And that she
was trying to figure out like.
>> [multiple speakers]
What's going on.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: Maybe
should I bite you, you know.
>> Juli Berwald:
That's interesting.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
Well, you both seem to
have had experiences
that partly involve figuring
out how to think about a type
of animal that a lot of people
grow up without a framework for.
How do you think
about this animal?
Do you think about it
more like a dog or a cat?
Or do you think about it more
like a worm or a plant even?
And one of the things
that made me think about,
I mentioned before my
dog likes the Kong.
My dog totally accidentally
the other day caught me
with a tooth.
That's what this is.
And I spent so much time
trying to figure out,
I realized I was thinking
about it in terms of like,
well, he didn't mean it.
Which is a very weird,
very human way to try
to analyze animal behavior.
And it's very difficult I
think to get out of that habit
of trying to think about an
animal the way would you think
about a person.
Especially if you're
close to them.
So what do you think, how do
you think about invertebrates
in general at this point?
What is your framework for kind
of thinking about jellyfish?
>> Juli Berwald: I think I've
always seen invertebrates
as the rulers of our world.
I mean, as Sy said, there's
way more invertebrates
than vertebrates.
And, you know, they
were here before us.
And they will be here after us.
And, yeah, I think to
see it as a reflection
of us all the time is maybe a
little self-centered, you know.
And I think, but I do think
that we have reached the stage
where we are very
powerful on this planet.
And we're changing it
at a chemical level that's
extremely, yeah, scary.
And so, you know, the,
I think the cephalopods
and the Cnidarians will
weather that storm.
Probably more easily than I do.
I think that's where my
thoughts go most often
when I think about
invertebrates.
Because they've been
through it before.
They've been through
massive shifts
in the planet's climate
and temperature.
And they have very ancient
behaviors that, you know,
that allow them to
withstand those things.
Like jellyfish, some
jellyfish can walk along,
when they're in the polyp stage.
Which is like the
sea anemone stage.
They can walk along the
sea floor and leave parts
of their feet, parts
of the bottom
of them behind almost
like a little seed.
And those seeds can live for a
decade or more, we don't know,
until conditions change.
And then burst out and
become a polyp again.
So I don't know how, yeah,
I feel like they have very,
very good behaviors that can
protect them more than us.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Juli Berwald: That's what
I think about most often.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
How do you think about the
octopus these days, Sy?
>> Sy Montgomery: Well, they are
so, the thing that is striking
to me is that, as alien as
they seem, they are very much
like us in the way we think.
One thing that I
learned in my research
from a scientist who's
been studying octopuses
for a long time.
Dr. Jennifer Mather
[assumed spelling].
Is that the same
neurotransmitters
that we have when we're in love.
When we're frightened.
When we're happy.
Those same neurotransmitters
are present in all animals
that they've ever looked for.
Including oxytocin.
Which you may have heard of,
that's the cuddle hormone.
It's called the cuddle hormone.
It's actually like
a social hormone.
But in mammals it
facilitates milk let down.
It facilitates social
bonding with your offspring.
Well, octopuses have their eggs
at the very end of their lives.
They use their last breath
to blow their tiny
paralarvae out of their lair.
They don't have maternal
care after that.
They don't get to
know their children.
But they have a neurotransmitter
so like oxytocin.
It's called cephalotocin.
So as different as we are,
in a very basic way we're
also shockingly similar.
So I think one of
the greater sins
than anthropomorphism
is anthropocentrism.
Believing it is all about us.
And just as you pointed
out that they have these
incredible abilities.
I mean, being able
to leave pieces
of your feet as,
in your footsteps.
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
>> Sy Montgomery: For
pieces of you to grow up.
My gosh. I mean, okay.
So we can, we invented
writing, but.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: But, wow.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Juli Berwald: We're
not leaving pieces
of our feet behind.
Yeah. Actually, on that topic,
it's actually very interesting.
After my book was published, it
turns out some graduate students
at Cal Tech were messing
around with jellyfish.
And they were watching them,
and they were like, oh,
they seem to chill out at night.
Like what's up with that?
And it turns out
jellyfish can sleep.
And they actually put
melatonin in the tank,
and it put the jellyfish
to sleep.
>> Sy Montgomery: Wow.
>> Juli Berwald:
So just like us.
>> Sy Montgomery: The receptors.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah, just.
>> Sy Montgomery: Yeah.
>> Juli Berwald:
The same receptors.
You know, melatonin is a
sleep receptor or transmitter,
I don't know what exactly it is.
But, anyway, it helps us sleep.
And it works on jellyfish too.
So these neurotransmitters,
you know, these chemicals
that affect our behaviors
come to us
from a very, very long time ago.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah.
>> Juli Berwald: And we
do share a lot in common
with these animals that
are even, you know,
500 or 650 million years old.
>> Sy Montgomery:
So we're all family.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: And that's
the way we should behave.
>> Linda Holmes: Well, we
have enough time for just,
I think, a few questions.
If people have questions
about an octopus,
a jellyfish that you
might have known.
Or not known.
Go ahead.
>> Thank you.
This is really, really
interesting.
If I go to the Baltimore
Aquarium
and I ask the people there about
the octopus or the jellyfish.
Are they on board with
what you're saying?
Are they, you know, the
relationship between you
and aquariums to get
your information.
The research that you did.
I mean, will they give me
the same kind of information
that you're giving out today?
Or are they, you know,
more cutting edge?
Are they behind?
Or, you know, what is it?
Because a lot of people
will go to an aquarium
to find information
about sea life.
>> Sy Montgomery: Well, a
lot of the, I have found
that the keepers of octopus
always named their octopus.
Even when they weren't
supposed to.
And a lot of the stuff
that scientists later found
out just bore out things that
the people who actually worked
with these animals already knew.
They already knew how smart
these animals were before we
gave them anything
like IQ tests.
And we're actually going
to the Baltimore Aquarium.
And I've been there before,
and I've met some of the folks
who are volunteers
and who work there.
And they seem to have great
respect for their creatures.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
I don't know people at
the Baltimore Aquarium.
But at the jellyfish
facilities I've been to,
like in Monterey Bay.
Those jellyfish breeders
are unbelievable.
And they know, they are, they go
to all the scientific
meetings with the scientists.
And they are scientists.
So they know, yeah, they know
very much about jellyfish.
I don't know all aquaria.
But, yeah, the ones I've talked
to are incredibly knowledgeable.
>> Thank you.
>> Linda Holmes: Thanks so much.
Okay, we're going
to go over here.
>> Thank you so much.
Very provocative.
Looking forward to
read both books.
>> Juli Berwald: Thank you.
>> With the products and
inventions that have come
from biomimicry, could you talk
a little about any breakthroughs
that either through octopuses
or jellyfish we've been able
to make some breakthroughs?
>> Juli Berwald: I
have a great story.
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh, good, go.
>> Juli Berwald: So I went
and talked to so robotic,
some people making
robotic jellyfish.
And this is really one of my
favorite stories in the book.
But by trying to make jellyfish
robots, they discovered
that it's not the
push of the jellyfish
that makes it go forward.
It's actually that
peplum, the flap,
the very pretty part
of the jelly.
It doesn't have any
muscles in it.
But just the movement of it
is actually what drives the
jellyfish forward
through the water.
And what they later
discovered is
that the wiggle creates
these turbulent eddies
that create a low pressure
system in front of the animal.
So jellyfish are actually
sucking themselves
through the water.
Like if you take a breath, yeah.
And if you start looking
around in the ocean,
you start noticing how
does everything swim?
Well, they all wiggle.
Everything wiggles.
And the reason for that wiggle
is to create this low pressure
that pulls marine creatures
and aquatic creatures
through the water
rather than pushes.
And we're so, you know,
we're so terrestrial.
When we walk, we push back
on the ground behind us.
But that's not what
goes not in the ocean.
So extraordinary discovery.
And it came from looking
at jellyfish swimming.
>> Sy Montgomery: That is great.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Sy Montgomery: Well, and
I know that they are looking
at octopuses as models for
soft robots, for example.
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
>> Sy Montgomery: So, I mean,
because they're just
made like nothing else.
>> Juli Berwald: Right.
>> Sy Montgomery: And they
have such strength, you know,
to be able, and they have
strength and precision.
The sucker is so dexterous.
It's super strong.
As I mentioned earlier, 3.5-inch
sucker can lift 30 pounds.
But it's also dexterous enough
that they can untie
knots in surgical silk.
Which they discovered when
they did operations on octopus.
And they, in the
morning they come in
and all this silk
is just untied.
>> Linda Holmes: All right,
let's go back over here.
>> Thank you both
for being here.
I grew up in Hawaii, and
I love eating octopus.
And so, but I'm also fascinated
by both jellyfish and octopus.
And I know that both
are delicacies.
And so I was just wondering
what your thoughts were on both
of them being delicacies?
>> Sy Montgomery: Does any, I'm
probably pronouncing it wrong.
But they call it
hey-e [phonetic].
>> I grew up with it,
in the Japanese, taco.
So I know it as taco.
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh, I've been
a vegetarian for a long time.
So, yeah, I'm not
going to eat them.
But a lot of people
have come up to me
after reading the book
saying, I can't eat them now.
But I tell people, you
know, good for you.
But if you want to
help octopuses,
the most important thing
you can do is help the sea.
And helping the sea, probably
the most important thing you can
do is try to stop or
slow global warming.
Because it is affecting
the sea worse.
[ Applause ]
>> Linda Holmes: You
talked a little bit
about eating jellyfish.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
Jellyfish have been eaten
in Asia for 1,000 years.
And they are all protein.
And they are packed
with antioxidants.
So they have been kind of used
also pharmaceutically for things
like arthritis, rheumatoid
arthritis.
Understanding what
that would mean
for western markets is still
sort of being explored.
And I tasted them
when I went to Japan,
chasing the giant jellyfish
which grows to be 500 pounds.
I went out with a
commercial fisherman,
and we caught jellyfish.
And his wife served me
some jellyfish salad.
And to me it tasted very
much like green pepper.
It was really, really not
exotic tasting at all.
So the thing is one of
the ways they preserve it.
Jellyfish were are watery.
They're 95 percent water.
That you have to
kind of pickle them.
You have to pull the water
out really fast or they spoil.
And they use this
salt called alum,
which isn't very
good for us, in Asia.
And then what they do is they
rinse it, and they pull the alum
out before they turn
it into a salad.
But that's probably not
going to fly western markets.
So there's Italians, Italian
foodies who are looking at it.
Doing other things like
sous-vide or fast freezing.
And, anyway, you know,
there are so many,
in places where the
oceans are out of kilter
and the blooms are really big.
There is this question of,
should we be eating
jellyfish, you know.
And so I don't think that
question is settled right now.
I think it's one of these
kind of emerging questions
and answers that we really are
going to have to think about.
It's not as clear
as with octopus.
>> Sy Montgomery: Well,
sea turtles eat jellyfish.
>> Juli Berwald:
Yes, sea turtles.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Sy Montgomery: And sea turtle
populations are plummeting.
I don't know if that's
also contributing.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah, they are.
In fact, people who study sea
turtles look for the jellyfish.
That go out on airplanes
looking for jellyfish in order
to find the sea turtles.
Yeah.
>> Linda Holmes: All
right, let's go over here.
>> Thank you.
I guess the biggest question
I have is, even listening
to you guys talk, that
we separate ourselves
from the animal kingdom.
And if we brought
ourselves back into it,
could we deal with these issues?
You know, a little,
make it closer to home.
And I'm not sure if that's
anything you can answer, but.
>> Sy Montgomery:
That's why I write.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah, I
don't think it would hurt.
>> Sy Montgomery: No, I think,
you know, the us and them thing.
If it's them, you can do
anything you want to them.
But if it's us, if
we're all one family,
then it's a whole
different thing.
It's about expanding your
capacity for compassion.
I think you hit the
nail on the head.
>> Thank you.
>> Linda Holmes: Okay.
>> Juli, a lot of book
clubs read your book.
And I can't believe that they're
just reading about jellyfish.
>> Juli Berwald: I can't either.
>> What is it about your book
that book clubs seem
to be drawn to?
>> Juli Berwald: So the
book is not just science.
There's memoir, as Sy's
book has memoir also.
And the book is about
me learning
to grow my own spine
as a writer.
And so my story is in there.
You can find out
about, you know,
my terrible grad
school experiences.
And my bad boyfriend.
And, you know, like
lots of things
that hopefully help the
reader move through the book.
And see how I really grew
as I followed jellyfish
around the world.
And tried to understand
what's happening
with them in today's oceans.
And, you know, I, the reason
it's called "Spineless" is
because jellyfish are spineless.
And because I had to kind
of grow my own spine.
And then because of our
collective spinelessness towards
the health of our
planet as Sy was saying.
[ Applause ]
>> Linda Holmes: All right, I
think we can get through both
of these if we go quick.
>> In either of your research,
did you encounter experiments,
for lack of a better word,
with invertebrates and music?
>> Juli Berwald: I'm sorry.
>> Invertebrates and music.
>> Juli Berwald: Oh.
>> Sy Montgomery: I don't think
octopuses can hear the way
that we do.
Although they certainly
sense vibrations.
And, boy, if you
wanted someone to dance,
no one could be more graceful.
>> Juli Berwald: I
did not find anything
with jellyfish and music.
But it's a great question.
I know they can sense currents.
And it's, oh, I do
have one story.
Yeah. When the jellyfish
stinging cell,
the stinging cell actually has
hair cells just like inside
of our ears as a
trigger mechanism.
And they listen for the
buzz of a zooplankton.
Which would be like
the buzz of a fly.
>> Sy Montgomery: Oh, my gosh.
>> Juli Berwald: And if
it's the correct frequency.
And they can also have these,
there's these sugar sensors
that smell like zooplankton
are kind of like pigpen.
They give off all these sugars.
And so, if it senses
both the sugars
and the correct frequency,
then it will trigger the cell.
And then it gets even crazier.
They also have a sensor
that smells proline.
Which is in crustacean blood.
And they twist those hair cells
so that they detect
a higher frequency.
And if they smell, it's
like hitting a zooplankton.
It will panic, and it will
buzz at a higher frequency.
And its blood will
be in the water.
It will send off a second
battery of stinging cells.
So, and they've actually, the
jellyfish have repair proteins
to fix those hair cells
on their stinging cells
if they are disrupted.
In our cochlea we
don't have them.
Which is why, when we hear
loud noises, we can go deaf.
And they have extracted
those repair proteins from,
actually from sea anemones.
Which are easier
to grow in the lab.
And applied them to
damaged mouse cochlea.
And it repaired the hair
proteins in the cochlea.
So they're looking at it
as, more for military.
Like if you're around
a big explosion,
they are could get
this, repair proteins
in your inner ear
and fix that up.
So, yeah, that's the only sound
and jellyfish answer
I have, but.
>> Linda Holmes: Yeah,
sounds like they have
everything they need
to hear music certainly.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
>> Linda Holmes: All right.
>> Sy, I think one of my
favorite parts of your book is
when you talk about
the sea star.
And how, I think
it was a sea star.
And how he's trying to get
the food from the octopus
or interested in when they're
feeding the octopus in the tank.
And so I was wondering if
you and, Juli, also yourself,
if you're planning on
writing any more books
about invertebrates.
I just found this topic
really fascinating.
And would love to learn more
about some other animals
that are out there
in this category.
>> Sy Montgomery: Boy, well,
there's certainly, there's a lot
of potential subjects out there.
Because most of us are
marine invertebrates,
most of us animals on Earth.
So, yeah, I would love to.
I have a memoir coming
out later this month
in which we have a
little more on octopus.
Because they're almost an
inexhaustible to write about.
But the next book I'm
researching is actually not a
marine invertebrate.
But it's actually, it's rays.
Marine vertebrate.
But, yeah, I'd love to.
I would love to do more.
>> Juli Berwald: Yeah.
I started actually on a fiction
book about a 16-year-old girl
who saves the world
from climate change.
So I really want to get that,
but I think there's
a coral book in me.
>> Linda Holmes: Fantastic.
Well, thank you guys so much.
And thank all of
you for being here.
Sy and Juli, thank you
guys for being here.